[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام معانا طاهر
براكي احييكم
مبلغ
ولي العهد السعودي يعلن تخصيص مليارين
ونصف الملياردولار لدعم مشروعات مبادره
الشرق الاوسط اخضر على مدار 10 سنوات
بدعوته للتصويت للجمهوريين وترامب وموالوه
يستعدون للفوز او التشكيكه
في اول مقابله مع محطه عربيه سوناك يؤكد
للعربيه اذانه لندن لتدخلات ايران في
المنطقه ويثمن العلاقات مع الخليج
وهتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
في كواليس صراع اوكرانيا واشنطن تواصل مع
موسكو هندسه الحرب كي لا يحشر بوتا في
الزاويه وفي يده زر النووي
[موسيقى]
اعلن ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان ان المملكه ستخصص مليارين ونصف
الملياردولار من اجل مبادره خضراء بالشرق
الاوسط على مدار السنوات ال 10 المقبله
وستضيف مقرها الرئيس
تاكيد على الزمن المملكه بجهوده بجهود
استلام استلام الدوليه
اعمل عن استضافه المملكه مقر الامانه
العامل مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر
وقرارها للسهام بمبلغ مليارين و500 مليون
دولار دعما لمشروعاتها مبادره والميزانيه
الامال العامه على مدن عشر سنوات القادمه
اليوم على استهداف صندوق استمارات العامه
للوصول الحياد الصفري الانبعاثات غاز
الاحتباس الحراري بحلول عام 20 50 من خلال
نهج الاقتصاد الدائري الكربون ويكون من
اوائل الصناديق الثروه السياديه عالميا
والاول في منطقه الشرق الاوسط في استهدافه
وصول الحياه الصفري بحلول عام 20 50 مما
يعزز دور الصندوق كلاعب الرئيسيه في دعم
الجهود العالميه في مواجهه التحديات
المناخ
كما اكد ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان ان السعوديه تسعى الى ان تمثل
الطاقه المتجدده 50 بالمئه من الاستهلاك
في 2030
باكثر من
278,000,000 طن مكافئ ثاني اكسيد الكربون
بحلول 20 30 من خلال تطبيق منهج الاقتصاد
الدائري الكربون والطلاق العديد من
مبادرات الاخرى منها منصه التعاون الدوليه
لتطبيق هذا النهج وصندوق استثماري اقليمي
مخصصه لتمويل تقنيات الاقتصاد الدائره
الكربون مبادره الحلول والوقود النظيف من
اجل توفير الغذاء
كما قامت المملكه بتسريع اوتيله تطير
وتبني التقنيات ومصادر الطاقه النظيفه
المتمثله باستخدام الطاقه المتجدده بهدف
اداره انبعاثات ومن موارد الهيدروكربونيه
وابراز هذه الخطوه
يمثل يتمثل في تتويج مزيج الطاقه المستخدم
في توليد الكهرباء في المملكه بحيث يتم
انتاج 50% من الكهرباء داخل المملكه
بالاعتماد على مصادر الطاقه متجدده بحلول
20 30
كان رئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي اعتبر
مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر فرصه لتعزيز
التعاون بين الدول لتمويل مشاريع مواجهه
تغير المناخ
فان مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر تمثل فرصه
ممتازه لتعزيز التعامل بين اعضائها من
الدول بهدف حشد المزيد من الاستثمارات
وتوفير اليات جديده للتمويل المبتكر لدعم
المشروعات التي تقوم بها دولنا لمواجهه
تغير المناخ بالتنسيق مؤسسه تمويل
العربيتين
التي تتطلع بدون مهم في هذا الاطار
يوسف الشماري من المنطقه الشرقيه وهو
باحثهم في جامعه
اهلا بك دكتور يوسف يعني نتحدث هنا عن
مبادرات الشرق الاوسط الاخضر التي تحدث
عنها ولي العهد السعودي يبدو انها ليست
مبادره مناخيه فقط انما هي ايضا مبادره
اقتصاديه لانها تدعم مشاريع تعمل بالطاقه
الخضراء
وصديقه للبيئه حدثنا عن ازدواجيه الفوائد
لهذه المبادره
اهلا وسهلا وسعيد في الحديث مع العربيه
هذا المساء طبعا لما يكون عندنا احنا اللي
هو الفاديتيشن واللي هو المسؤلات
استزراع الاراضي
واللي هي طبعا الهم بعدها القضاء الاعلى
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه المملكه الخضراء
والشرق الاوسط الاخضر طبعا نحنا كل لانه
احنا العالمي مول العافيه مساله اللي هي
التصنيع عمليات اللي هي الثوره الصناعيه
ايش ينتج عنها ينتج عنها انبعاثات
للكهرباء لكن مقابل هذا كل شجره ممكن تزرع
اللي هي مقابل العمليات هذا الستيشن
وهتقطع الاشجار بتحصل في العديد من الدول
العالم نتيجه عمليات العمليات
التصنيعشن فينتج عنها في الاخير اللي هو
الانتصاص للشجره ايش تعمل امتصاص ثاني
اكسيد الكربون تطلع اللي هو الاكسجين
عمليه اللي هو التمثيل الضوئي حسب ما همم
قال باللغه العربيه همم
في عمليات النمو الاقتصادي استهلاك الاكبر
طبعا عمليات الطاقه والتعويض عن كميات
الكربون اللي تنتج عن عمليات الصناعيه هذا
من عامل والعامل الاخر انه العامل الغذاء
او الالحاق في الاثر والبيئه نتيجه
العمليات الصناعيه سيكون اقل فاحنا في
الاخر اضافه طبعا العمل اللي هو الدول بي
في ناحيه جوده الهواء وايضا لتقليل مثلا
المساله الغبار ومساله والاعمى النظام
الالكترونيكولوجي كله طبعا يتم تحصينه
بشكل جدا كبير مع عمليات اللي هو زراعه
الاشياء لو نلاحظ مثلا بث في البرازيل
طبعا اللي هو الغابات الامازون جزء جدا
كبير حسب ما انا اعلم انه احدث اسباب
البرازيل طبعا مستمر في الدفاع ستيشن على
التقطيع الاجسام الغابات الامازون اللي هي
في العقيقه تمثل رئه كوكب الارض ولكن مع
كل هذه التحديات دكتور يوسف همم البعض قد
يجد انه في بعض من التناقض فيما يتم طرحه
عالميا لانه بعد الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه كان في دعوات الى على الاقل
على الاقل ابطا التحول نحو الطاقه النظيفه
النظيفه بشكل كامل والعوده الى النفط
التقليدي والى الطاقه التقليديه من اجل
انقاذ العالم في المرحله الحرجه التي يمر
بها هل يمكن السير بخطاين متوازيين هنا هو
اخي طاهر ما ما نقدر نقول احنا لا نفط او
طاقه نظيفه هو او مجرد الطاقه نظيفه
لحالها من دون نقص لازم يكون هنالك في
اللي هو ال- ال-
اللي هو طريقه همم يعني همم متحده لكل
جميع مصادر الطاقه مثلا في اعطيك مثلا
مثال تصيح مثلا
انه هو محتاج انه يكون هنالك مثلا تسريع
للتحول الطاقه المتجدده هو يناقد تصريح
رئيسه الوزراء السابقه راس اللي همم طبعا
كان هنالك عندها توجه مختلف انه تجعل
بريطانيا مصدده من النص في عام 2040 فاا
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ايش توجهها
توجهها ان جميع مصادر الطاقه بس اوع
الطاقه متجدده او طاقه احفوريه هي جايه من
النفط والغاز لكن النفط والغاز استخداماته
في المستقبل لا تكون زي استخداماته في ال
20 او 50 سنه ماضيه
استخدامه ضمن اقتصاد الكربون الدائري كل
الكربون يطلع من استخدام النفط والغاز
يستم احتجازه لتحويل الكربون الى عمليات
اخرى
نعم نعم
للطاقه همم ولكن همم لافت لفتني تصريح ل
همم رئيس الفرنسي يتحدث بانه يجب التخلص
من الاعتماد على الوقود الاحفوري والتوجه
الى التعاقد ذريه فعليا همم
والتكنولوجيا اصلا المشغل للطاقه الذريه
تمتلكها فرنسا والعديد من الدول لا تمتلك
بالتالي ما اهميه ان يكون هناك تعاون دولي
خاصه هذا ما يتم التاكيد عليه بقمه المناخ
والا تلتفت كل دوله الى مصالحها الخاصه
في اوروبا لو نتكلم عن اوروبا او الاتحاد
الاوروبي قد يكون هذا الطريقه هذه تكون
فعال تعزز اوبا من مزيج الطاقه النوويه قد
لكن هيواجه الصعوبه في المانيا في النمس
يعني تكون
ضد الطاقه النوويه فاعتقد قد يكون من
الصعب تنفيذ هذه الاستراتيجيه اللي همم
طبعا رئيس الفرنسي طبعا في فرنسا طبعا
افضل من ايام
مكان هنالك في تعزيز الطاقه النوويه حوالي
70% من الطاقه الكهربائيه في فرنسا من
الطاقه النوويه لكن لا يزال الغاز مصدر
جدا مهمه الطاقه شوفي بس لما حصلت ازمه
الغاز ولما انقطع الامتدادات الروسيه ايش
حصل في القائمه الاوروبيه حاليا ما يحصل
حاليا من ارتفاع في اسعار الغاز من تباطؤ
في النمو الاقتصادي من ارتفاع اسعار
الكهرباء فالغاز جدا مهم حتى على المدى
البعيد 20 الى 50 سنه سيتم سيبقى الغاز
مصدر المهم للطاقه الكهربائيه حتى ان كان
هنالك في تعزيز استخدام الطاقه النوويه
هذا حتى في الدول المتقدمه نعم لما نيجي
للدول الناميه التقنيه غير موجوده خصوصا
لما نتكلم عن افريقيا هناك ازمه ازمه فقط
الطاقه في الهند في العديد من من الدول
المختلفه صحيح لا لا الخيار النووي ليس
موجود
يعني على الطاوله ما اعتقد تحتاج لها
حياه تخرج من دوله لدوله قراءه وفيها شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور يوسف الشمري الباحث في
جامعه لندن تحياتنا اليك العفو العفو اذا
راويه ينعقد مؤتمر المناخ كوب 27 في شرم
الشيخ المصريه في ظل ظروف عالميه معقده
سياسيا اقتصاديا وحتى مناخيا كانه الارض
على وقع انبعاثات الكربون المتزايده
والوعود بموقف دولي حاسم للتغيير وعود لم
تخرج من الورق الى الواقع منذ العام 2020
بقياده كبار الملوثين في العالم
تصدرت الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده
قائمه المقصرين بالتمويل المناخي وتقديم
الحصه العادله التي تتناسب وحجم الضرر
المناخي الصادر من اراضيه
تقصير الكبار في تعهداتهم كان محل لون
واستياء الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون
موجهن سهاما انتقاده تحديدا الى امريكا
والصين فهما لم تخفضان بعثاتهما ولا
التزمتا بتعهداتهما الملكيه تعاهدت الدول
الغنيه بتقديم 100 مليار دولار سنويا
بحلول 20 20 لكن الهدف لم يتحقق لكن من
الذي تقاعس حصه الولايات المتحده مثلا
بناء على انبعاثاتها السابقه 40 مليار
دولار لكنها قدمت 7.6 مليار دولار فقط في
عام 2020 في المقابله قدمت استراليا وكندا
حاول ثلث التمويل المطلوب منهما بينما
قدمت المملكه المتحده ثلاثه ارباع التموين
لكنها لا تزال تتخلف بمقدار مليار واربع
مئه مليون دولار لانه نتابع معكم اكثر
مقدار العجز في التمويل
[موسيقى]
على الجهه الاخرى هناك من مول المناخ
باكثر من اضعاف قصته المفروضه سويسرا مثلا
قدمت اربعه اضعاف المبلغ بينما كانت تمويل
فرنسا والنرويج اكثر من ثلاثه اضعاف
المبلغ اليابان ايضا هي واحده من اكبر
ممولين قدم 13 مليار دولار اي اكثر من ضعف
المبلغ المطلوب منها لكن
وراء هذا السخاء تمويل اليابان وفرنسا كان
في معظمه على شكل قروض في حين كانت تمويل
من الولايات المتحده وكندا واستراليا
والمملكه المتحده في غالبيته كان من حمى
والطبع تفضل البلدان الناميه تفضل ذلك
بالشده نتابع معكم مقدار قائد التمويل
المناخي لبعض الدول
[موسيقى]
يعول على مؤتمر كوب 27 بان تكون قضيه
تمويل المناخ حاسمه فيه لاحراز التقدم
المنشود تواجه البلدان ضعيفه حاله حياه او
موت واثقه صحيفه تجارديان البريطانيه
وتحتاج الى اكثر من 100 مليار دولار كان
الهدف من المئه مليار دولار تلك دعم خفض
انبعاثات الكربون والعمل على تكييف
المجتمعات مع الطقس القاسي المتزايد
الناتج عن الاحتباس الحراري ومع ذلك كشفت
سلسله من التقارير الاسبوع الماضي عن مدى
قرب الكوكب من كارثه المناخ مع عدم وجود
مسار موثوق لخفض الكربون الى درجه ونصف
مئويه وهو الحد الاقصى متفق عليه دوليا
لدرجه الحراره لتجنب السوء ازمه مناخيهرش
ويعرض فايت تفاولايت
في مواجهه التغير المناخي ونحن نخسر
ارتفاع درجات الحراره حول العالم مستمر
والخطر كبير الحرب في اوكرانيا والصراعات
واعمال العنف القت بظلالها على العالم يجب
الا نركز فقط على حل الصراعات وننسى مشكله
المناخ لان المناخ يمثل تحديا كبيرا لنا
الفوضى المناخيه هي السبب الرئيس في
الصراعات العالميه الحرب على البيئه
انتهاك خطير لحقوق الانسان هناك تحذيرات
علميه من حقيقه ارتفاع درجات الحراره ما
يعني اننا نقترب من نقطه لا عوده
تقرير كشف ان خمسه دول فقط هي اليابان
وايطاليا وهولندا والنرويج والسويد زاد
التعاهداتها بالتمويل منذ عام 20 21 قال
رئيس كوب 26 اللوك شارما الذي كلف باعداد
التقرير ان هناك حاجه الى التريليونات
الدولارات بشكل عام
لترد الحكومه الكنديه بانها ضاعفت تمويلها
الدوليه للمناخ الى 5.3 مليار دولار خلال
فتره خمس سنوات بدءا من عام 20 واحد و 20
تقول راشيل سيمون من شبكه العمل المناخيه
في اوروبا ان العالم يراقب والساعه تدق
سنحاسب الحكومات في كوب 27 للتاكد من انها
تسير على المسار الصحيح المال موجود
ولكنها مساله اراده سياسيه فقط
تمويل الطارئ مطلوب بشده لكن الظروف
الدوليه الاقتصاديه والس هي نتساعد كثيرا
فقمه كوب 27 تتزهما مع الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا التي مضى عليها ثمانيه اشهر
مسببه ازمه طاقه خانقه وتضخما عالميا
يزداد سوءا فقط الحرب في اوكرانيا ونقص
الطاقه المرتبطه بها على المخاوف المناخيه
الحكومات قليقه بشان انكماش الاقتصادي
وانهارت بعض التحالفات الرئيسيه المتبنيه
لقضايا المناخ وهي والات الحرب اذا بحسب
الرئيس المصري
انا باتكلم تحديدا هنا على الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
وبوجه النداء
من اجل ان تتوقف هذه الحرب
من فضلكم
نحن
كدول
اقتصادها
مش قوي
عن الكثير جدا من تبعات
ازمه كرونه سنتين
وتحملناها
والان معاني ايضا من هذه الحرب
ولكن انا بتكلم هنا عشان العالم كله اتصور
انه بيعاني من هذه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا الدول على اعاده
الانبعاثات الى الوراء بالعوده الى الوقود
الاحفوري والفحم تنقل صحيفه
و ستحرق اوروبا 220 مليون طن اضافي من
الفحم مقارنه بمكانه توقعاتنا قبل الحرب
اي ما يعادل لك اكثر من نصف مليار طن من
ثاني اكسيد الكربون كما يتزايد استخدام
الفحم في البلدان التي يتنامى فيها الطالب
على الطاقه تسع اسواق اسيويه كبيره بما في
ذلك الصين والهند يمثل الفحم ما لا يقل عن
ثلث الوقود المستخدم لتوليد الكهرباء فيها
بالحديث عن الصين وهي اكبر ملوث في العالم
فهي تسعى الى تحقيق التوازن بين اهداف
المناخ والحاجه الى امن الطاقه ومن دونها
لن يكون العالم قادرا على تحقيق هدف واحد
فاصل خمسه درجه مئويه والكلام لانطونيو
بوترش ستكون الاشعارات التي سترسلها قمه
مجموعه العشرين التي ستعقد في اندونيسيا
يومي الخامس عشر والسادس عشر من نوفمبر
حاسمه بالنسبه للقرارات التي اعتمدها كوب
27 لكنها ثقه كبيره في قمه شرم الشيخ
لايجاد الحلول للكوارث المناخيه التي
تتسارع وتيرتها والتي تسببت في ارتفاع عدد
الضحايا والنازحين بالاضافه الى الخسائر
الماديه التي تقدر بالمليارات
من اجل الاجابه عن تلك الاسئله
والرد على شواغل الملايين حول العالم
الذين يعانون الان
اكثر من اي وقت مضى من كوارث مناخيه
تتصارع وترتها
وتزداد حدتها على نحو غير مسبوق
يوما بعد يوم
في شتى انحاء كوكبنا
فما تلبس ان تنتهي كارثه في مكان ماء حتى
تبدا اخرى في مكان اخر
مخلفه وراءها الاف الضحايا والمصابين
والنازحين
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا
متى تلتقط عدوى تويتر ستبقي خطط الواقع
الافتراضيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ونفتح ملف الانتخابات
النصفيه الامريكيه وتغطيه مكثفه من
العربيه طيله يوم غدوه ليل غد ايضا لهذه
الانتخابات معنا نتائجها
امريكيه يصل الى اصواته الاخيره
في الولايات المتحده والولايات الحاسمه
فعليا هناك استعانوا بشخصيات بارزه من
احبابه في الساعات الاخيره انهم يرجحنا
كفتهم على حساب المنافسين في فلوريدا
استعانه المرشحون الجمهوريون برئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب الذي دعا الامريكيين للتصويت
لانقاذ الحلم الامريكي على حد وصفه ترامب
اشار كذلك الى ان الحزب مستمر بتوسيعه
قاعده الجماهيريه خاصه في اوساط المواطنين
من ذوي الاصول اللاتينيه الذين كان اغلبهم
يصوتون للديمقراطيه
اماكن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
للولايات المتحده لدعم المرشحين في
حملاتهم الانتخابيه مره ظهر الرئيس
الاخير
انتخابات يوم الثلاثاء نقطه تحول ستحدد
شكل البلاد في سنوات القادمه
سيختارون بين رؤيتين مختلفتين جوهريا
لامريكا
الموسم الموسم كامل
[موسيقى]
الانتخابيه التي قام بها تماما
السعيد
مثل الجريمه والاقتصاد مع الاعتراف
واستثمار المليارات في البنيه
الموجودين في وسط او على الحياد الصحيفه
اضافت ان الناخبين المترددين يبقون في
حاله التارجح لعده اسباب منها انهم
يعتبرون ان افكارهم هي مزيج من الحزبين
الرئيسيين وبشكل عام يميل هذا النوع لدعم
الحزب الذي لا يكون في السلطه وهو الامر
الذي تكرر خلال العقود الماضيه هو مدعى
اليه ايضا الى ماسك قبل ساعات بدعوى
الحفاظ على توازن السلطه
مع اقتراب الانتخابات نحن امام سعد قليله
فقط يعود التخوف للواجهه من عدم قبول
المرشحين نتائج الانتخابات حاله خسارتهم
كما فعل ترام سابقا العديد من المرشحين
الحاليين للانتخابات مثلا رفضوا الافصاح
اما اذا كانوا سيقبلون النتيجه وتراوحت
الردود بين عدم التعليق على السؤال او
الجزم بالفوز وحينها قبول نتيجه
الانتخابات اي قبول النتيجه فقط اذا فاز
المرشح هل سيقبل جمهوريون بنتيجه
الانتخابات سؤال طرح على رئيسه اللجنه
الوطنيه للحزب رونالاك دانيال التي قالت
ان مرشحين حزبها سيقبلون بالنتائج سواء
فازوا ام لا معبره عن رغبتها بان تجرى
الانتخابات
القلق عاد خاصه وانه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه قبل عامين كما نذكر روج الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب مع حلفائفه لمزاعم
بان الانتخابات قد سرقت حتى ان ترامب لم
يعترف حتى الان بهزيمته في الانتخابات
امام بيدن وعدد ترامب امس للخطاب ذاته
خلال جوله انتخابيه في فلوريدا واعاد
مزاعم سرقه الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على الجانب الاخر انتقد بايدا وجود اكثر
من 300 من المرشحين الجمهوريين لمختلف
المناصب ممن ينكرون نتيجه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه عام 2020 اعتبر ايضا ان تهديدات
بعض المرشحين الجمهوريين برفض قبول نتائج
الانتخابات اذا خسروا تشكل تهديدا
للديمقراطيه ملقيا باللوم على ترامب الذي
يروج لمزاعم سرقه الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
والله
دكتور وليد
ماذا تقول الساعات الاخيره قبيل
الانتخابات بشان ابرز العوامل التي
ستحسمها
اهم العناء العوامه العزيز الطاهره التي
سوف تحصل قد حصلت يعني حصلت في الاشهر
الماضيه 90 95 ربما 92% من العوامل
الاقتصاد الضرائب الصحه
الامان الحدود الامور التي تناقشوها بشكل
عام هذه حصلت الان هو القدره التنظيميه
يعني اخر واحد او اثنين بالمئه القدره
التنظيميه لهؤلاء المرشحين لكي يعبئوا
ياتوا بالناخبين الى مراكز اختراع لانه لا
ننسى الفرق بين هذه الانتخابات الرئاسيه
في 2020 كان وقتها
ملايين عشيرات ملايين من الامريكيين
بواسطه البريد وهذا لن يكون لن تكون الحال
هذه المراه دكتور وليد يعني اذا انتهى
الفرز واعلنه النتائج بفوز الديمقراطيين
في هذه الانتخابات النصفيه هل يمكن ان
نشهد احداث كابتل اثنين همم رده
للمتوقع برايك خاصه بانه هناك تقرير تتحدث
انه اليمين المتطرف يقبل بكثافه على شراء
السلاح في الولايات المتحده بالايام
الاخيره
هذه النظريه وهذه الدكتور تاتي من قبل
فيهم خائفون من ان يخسروا لان الفارق كبير
بين انتخابات الكونغرس وانتخابات الرئاسه
انتخابات الرئاسه الفوارق فيها لا يمكن
معرفتها الا في اخر ساعات او تنتظر يوم او
كاميرا هنا في انتخابات الماضيه ايام قبل
ان تعرف هنا الدائره الصغيره جدا
والمراقبين يعني كثيرون وبالتالي انتخابات
الكونجرس بشكل عام ليس فقط تعرف بشكل
مباشر بعد الانتخابات ولكن تقريبا تحسن من
قبل ذلك يعني كل الاستخبارات البولينج
يقول مثلا في مجلس النواب الفارق سوف يكون
بين 20 و30 نائب لصالح الجمهوريين البعض
يتخطى اكثر البعض يقول اقل النتيجه غير
المضمونه هي في مجلس الشيوخ يعني مجلس
الشيوخ منقسم في الوسط قد تكون لصالح
هؤلاء او او الاقسام لمقعد او مقاطعتين
اذا هذه النظريات نسمعها سمعنا منكم عن
الترام يتكلم عن الماضي وبيض يتكلم عن ما
يمكن ان يحدث هذه كل نظريات سياسيه طيب
معلش نسال قليلا عن التصور
لعلاقه الولايات المتحده بشؤون المنطقه
فيما لو اعاده ورجحت كافه الجمهوريين
وعادت السيطره ولو في الانتخابات النصفيه
وهوما قد يمهد لعودتهم في الرئاسه في 20
24 كيف سنعكس ذلك علينا باعتقادك صحيح هذا
ما قال لي لغدا ولكن سنلخص ما تقدر ههه
همم
اكثر واقعيه ان يربح الجمهوريون في مجلس
النواب ولكن ما احتمال لا باس به مجلس
الشيوخ مجلس الشيوخ يؤثر على تعيين
السفراء والوزراء الى هناك له تاثير اكبر
في السياسه الخارجيه ولكن مجلس النواب له
الميزانيات وبالتالي بامكانه ان يضغط على
البيت الابيض ماذا يعني كل ذلك السياسه
الخارجيه تبقى بين يدي البيت الابيض هذا
امر معروف حتى العام 2024 ولكن بيمكان
المجلس يعني الكونجرس بشكل عام او نصفه ان
يعطل السياسه الخارجيه ليس بامكانهم ان
يكونوا سياسه خارجيه جديده ليس لهم هذه
القدره ولكن بامكانهم ان يعارضوا ما يمكن
ان يحصل ان يتم التفاهم بين البيت الابيض
او الاداره السلطه التنفيذيه والكونغرس
على توافق قاعه اضرب مثل بموضوع الاتفاق
النووي الايراني مع هذا الكونغرس سوف يصعب
جدي همم على الرئيس ان يوقع ولكن اذا قرر
واراد ان يكون ان يكون بعكس يعاكس
الكونجرس دي واقعه بقرار تنفيذي وهذا ما
يكون ضعيف هذا مثل واحد من الامثال
الدكتور وليد الان خارجيه الامريكيه تقول
لنا تساهل مع اي تدخل بالانتخابات مهما
كان مصدر ذلك همم وقتنا انتهى ولكن هناك
تغريده لافته لان الماسك اليوم دعت الناس
الى التصويت للجمهوريين رايك بتوقيت هذه
التغريده وهذه الدعوه بعد ان اصبح الماسك
يعني يتربع على عرش اهم موقع للتواصل
الاجتماعي وهل ستؤثر بالناس هذه الدعوه
باختصار لو سمحت
الشركات ليس له خبره كبيره للسياسه هاجمه
اطراف من اليسار بعد ان اختلف معهم على
موضوع الاشاره الزرقاء فهو يرد ولكن هذا
لن يؤثر انا قلت منذ دقيقه واعود القول
المعركه قد خسمت ولكن لا نرى نتائجها
الكونجرس انتخابته مختلفه عن انتخابات
الرئاسه شكرا جزيلا على هذه القراءه دكتور
وليد فارس الخبير في شان الامريكي من
واشنطن
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
والبيت الابيض يقول الان تعليقات مسؤولين
رؤوس عن انتخابات التجديد النصفي لا
تفاجئنا بعد ما قلتي قبل قليل عن الخارجيه
الامريكيه مع اي تدخل بالانتخابات مهما
كان مصدر ذلك الى اول مقابله مع وسيله
اعلاميه عربيه الان
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك الذي
قال في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه ان
العلاقات بين بريطانيا ودول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي مهمه وتاريخيه انه يتطلع الى دفع
هذه العلاقات قدما والى تطويرها
اكشن كونان
باسماك سناب
[موسيقى]
عمري
اذا نتابع في هذا الموضوع لكن نشير اولا
الى ان البيت الابيض ايضا يقول بانه ليس
هناك تهديدات محدده ذات مصداقيه بخصوص يوم
الانتخابات
وايضا يقول بانه الرئيس بايدن احيطه علما
ايه
هذه التهديدات في المحيطه بالانتخابات
النصفيه يوم غد
التعليقات المسؤولين الروس تحديدا عن
انتخابات التجديد لا تفاجئ البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
ولكن من ما تناولناه بالامس في العربيه
360 حول الحديث عن ضغوط امريكيه على
القاده الاوكرانيين لاتخادي موقفا اكثر
لينا تجاه المفاوضات مع روسيا اليوم يكشف
مسؤولون امريكيون عن محادثات
القومي
مع كبار مساعدي الرئيس
في محاوله للحد من مخاطر نشوب صراع او صح
اوكرانيا
من استخدام الاسلحه النوويه او اسلحه
الدمار الشامل الاخرى وفقا لصحيفه واستج
جورنا الامريكيه
يبقى انت حدث مع يوري اوشاكووف مستشار
السياسه الخارجيه لبوتن ومع نظيره الروسي
نيكولاي بتروشيف والهدف والحمايه من مخاطر
التصعيد وابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه وليس
مناقشه تسويه للحرب في اوكرانيا لم يقر
البيت الابيض علنا باي مكالمات بين
سواليفن واي مسؤول روسي رفيع منذ مارس
الماضي وكذلك فعل الكلام بعدم التاكيد
المعلنه تاتي في الوقت الذي تضاءلت فيه
الاتصالات الدبلوماسيه التقليديه بين
واشنطن و موسكو الى ادنى مستوى منذ الحرب
البارده المتابع للتحركات الامريكيه سيرى
ان واشنطن تدير مسارات الحرب مثل ما تدير
عمليه المساعده لاوكرانيا كيف السلاح
النوويه خط احمر نصر روسيا خط احمر
وهزيمتها الكامله كذلك
[موسيقى]
لماذا نقول ذلك بحلول اكتوبر 20 21 كانت
الاستخبارات الامريكيه تستعد وعلى معرفه
تامه بان بوتن قرر شن الحرب على اوكرانيا
المديره وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
وليامبرز الى
نوفمبر من عام 2021 لتحذير بوتن من الغزو
تفاجا بتروشيف عينها حينها من معرفه
المسؤول الروسي ان على قوات مسكوا التوقف
عن مهاجمه المدن والبلدات الاوكرانيه وحذر
الكراملين من استخدام الاسلحه الكيميائيه
او البيولوجيا
الاستخبارات الوطنيه الامريكيه تحضر
بروكسل واوروبا للحرب بينما كان انتون
بلينكن وزير الخارجيه في كياف يحذر ويجهز
المعني الاول بالحرب
اربع قواعد القاعده الاولى لا صراعه
مباشره بين الجيش الامريكي وحلف شمال
الاطلسي من جهه وروسيا من جهه ثانيه
القاعده الثانيه
التواء الحرب داخل الحدود الجغرافيه
لاوكرانيا
تعزيز وحده الناتو والحفاظ عليها والرابعه
هيئه تمكين اوكرانيا ومنحها وسائل القتال
وبالتالي لنصره كامل ولا هزيمه كامله كما
اسلفناها ومهما بلغت ازمه تجده موسكو
واشنطن اشياء مشتركه للحفاظ على الاتصال
بينهما ومنها التزامهما بمعاهده نيو ستارت
التي تحد من الاسلحه النوويه طويله المدى
لامريكا وروسيا والتي من المقرر ان تنتهي
في 20 26 ويخ المسؤولون الامريكيون والروس
لعقد اجتماعات اللجنه الاستشاريه الثنائيه
التي انشاتها معاهده ستارت لمناقشه
تنفيذها وفقا لمسؤولين امريكيين ما كانت
سويسرا الدوله المضيفه التقليديه لمثل هذه
المحادثات قالت موسكو انها لم تعد تعتبرها
دوله محايده لانها فرضت عقوبات اقتصاديه
في اعقب الحرب الروسيه على موسكو ومع
تشامك هذه الملفات قد يظهر وسيط لم يكن في
الحسبان مصر يدور حديث عن استضافات
القاهره لهذه الاجتماعات في اواخر نوفمبر
الجاري في القاهره تحافظ على موقف متوازن
بين الاطراف راويه سواء واشنطن موسكو او
موسكو وكاف علاقتها المميزه قد تكون السر
في اضافه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من الرياض في عوده الى موضوع
وهي اول تصريحات وسيله اعلام اعلاميه
عربيه دكتور فهد بن جمعه عضو مجلس الطاقه
والاقتصاد في مجلس الشورى سابقا اهلا بكم
معنا دكتور فهد في العربيه 360 يتحدث
سوناك بثقه عن نيته تطوير العلاقات مع
الخليج ودفع هذه العلاقات قدما هل ما
ينطبق في الفتره الحاليه في العلاقه بين
الرياض والولايات المتحده همم يعني لا
ينطبق على العلاقه مع لندن ام اننا نتحدث
عن جهه موحده
اهلا وسهلا انا اعتقد انها علاقه دول
الخليج والمملكه مع امريكا ومع بريطانيا
هي علاقات طبيعيه
وطبعا يحدث بعض الاحيان لبعض الخلافات
ولكن هي علاقات طبيعيه وما زالت امريكا هي
همم الاهم عالميا في الاقتصاديات العالميه
وايضا علاقه مع دوله مثل بريطانيا هي
علاقات مهمه في تبادل التجاري
والخبرات تبادل الخبرات والتقنيه وغيرها
وكذلك في امن المنطقه المشاركه كلها
علاقات مهمه امريكا وبريطانيا
عندما يتحدث رئيس وزراء دوله كبرى مثل
بريطانيا ويقول بانه الان وضع ايران اصبح
اكثر صعوبه وانه يعلم دورها
لا يشكل ربما اشارات او فرصه
لتعزيز التعاون الخليجي البريطاني لكفيد
ايران عن زعزعت امن هذه المنطقه التي
يتحدث عنها
جدا على الدول المملكه ودول الخليج يعرفون
التهديدات الايرانيه والخطر الايراني على
امن واستقرار المنطقه همم هذه الدول
البريطانيا وغيرها كلها يعرفون جيدا ما
مدى خطوره همم مليشيات همم
الايرانيه وصواريخها وحتى الانتاج النووي
على المنطقه وعلى استقرارها وهي منطقه
يعني تنتج من النفق
يستطيع طلب العلم ويمثل خطر في اي نقص في
هذه الطاقه خاصه النفط في دول الخليج له
اثر كبير على الاقتصاد العالمي
والاعتراف حتى لو جاء متاخرا فهو ما زال
همم جيد ولكن هل انا الاوان لكي همم تكون
العلاقه السياسيه اكثر صراحه بجميع
مفرداتها مع المملكه المتحده في ما يتعلق
بما يجب اتخاذه من اجراءات فيما يتعلق بكل
ما يزعزع لاستقرار وان منطقه بمعنى انه
كما كان الحال مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بانه نحافظ على صداقتنا وعلى
حلفنا الاستراتيجي ولكن ليس مقابل التنكر
لمصالحنا هل ايضا اعود الى موضوع همم
امكانيه ان ينطبق ذلك على المملكه المتحده
في التعاطي معها وبالتالي اتخاذ اجراءات
قطعيه يعني نهائيا لضروره تحرك جدا من قبل
لندن تجاه هذا الموضوع والا يكون هناك
اجراءات من نوع اخر كلك التي تخذت مع
الولايات المتحده
المحصله كل دوله تسعى الى خدمه مصالح
عندما يكون هناك تحديث لمصالحها فهمناها
سوف تتدخل وغير ذلك لا يمكن اذا بريطانيا
لها المصالح وكذلك دول الخليج لها مصالح
وعندما تكون هذه المصالح متفقه في اتجاهها
انا اعتقد ان سوف يكون هناك تعاون امني
وتعاون اقتصادي ولكن كما نعرف نقرا
التاريخ
اصبحت التدخلات والمحافظه على الامن ليس
كما يتوقعها الكثير وانما كل دوله
يجب عليها ان تعز همم
مكانتها وامنها بنفسها وان تحافظ على مص
ولا يمنع المشاركه مع الدول مثل
البريطانيا وامريكا وغيرها لخدمه مصالحها
اذا ما كانت هناك مصالح كبيره ومشتركه بين
بريطانيا ودول الخليج نعم سوف تحاول
بريطانيا المحافظه
شكرا جزيلا على هذه القراءه دكتور فهد بن
جمعه عضو مجلس الطاقه والاقتصاد في مجلس
الشورى سابقا تحياتنا اليك
كالعربيه 360 ايضا وسط الحرب الاوكرانيه
غاره روسيه جديده قتلت تسعه اشخاص الغريب
لا احد تم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لانه متابع من تصريحات
الرئيس الفرنسي الخاصه بي العربيه تهديدات
ايران تجاوزت النطاق الاقليميه وعلينا
العمل بشكل منظم لمواجهه التهديدات
الايرانيه تاتي هذه التصريحات للرئيس
الفرنسي بعد المقابله الخاصه التي اجرتها
العربيه ايضا مع رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه
الجديده التي تحدث فيها ايضا عن التهديدات
الايراني
تاثر الشعب الايراني بالعقبات على نظامي
تسريحه الموظفين يبدو انها انتقلت من
تويتر الى متى شركه الامه للفيسبوك
انستغرام
الالاف من الموظفين بدءا من الاسبوع
الجاري الشركه سجلت نتائج فصليه مخيبه
للامل في الربع الثالث بتراجع قدره 52%
مقارنه بالعام الماضي حتى سبتمبر الماضي
ابهرت الاحصاءات ان عدد الموظفين في مكه
وصل لنحو 87.000 موظف
الالكترونيه التي يرتكز نموذجها
الاقتصاديه على الاعلانات من خفض المعلنين
لانفاقهم
[موسيقى]
اذا رئيس الفرنسي للعربيه تهديدات ايران
تجاوزت النطاق الاقليميه
[موسيقى]
شكرا راويه وطهر حياكم الله مشاهدينا الى
المجد الرياض سيكون الظهير المخدرم داني
البس ضمن قائمه المنتخب البرازيلي المشارك
في كاس العالم
البرازيل النهائيات بقياده نيمار يشكل
غيابه فيرمينو مهاجم ليفربول عن قائمه
المدرب تاتي المفاجاه الابرص بعد ما فضل
تيت الاستعانه بمهاجم ارسنال جابر في
النادي اللندنيه
مانشستر يونايتد انطونيو يعتبر المنتخب
البرازيلي من البرازيل المرشحين للمنافسه
على اللقب المونديال
كشفت مجموعه فنوي سبورت الامريكيه الملكه
لنادي ليفربول انها ستاخذ في الاعتبار
اتاحه الفرصه لمساهمين الجدد بعد ان تلقت
بشكل متكرر عروضا من اطراف ثالثه تعبر عن
اهتمامي بشراء اسهم في النادي مؤكده في
ذات الوقت بانها لا تزال ملتزمه بنجاحه
ليفربول داخل وخارج الملعب
اسفرت قرعه ثمن نهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا
عن مواجهه تجمع ريال مدريد الاسباني حامل
اللقب مع ليفربول الانجليزي في تكرار
لنهائي نسخه الموسم الماضي وسيجد باريس
سان جيرمان الفرنسي نفسه امام مواجهه قويه
تجمعه ببايرن من خلال الالماني الذي ينهى
دور المجموعات بالعلامه
واسفلت القرعه تعلقه المتوازنه تجمع بين
ميلان وتوتنهام وبروسيا دورتموند ضد
تشيلسي وانتر ميلان مع بورتو مانشستر سيتي
كما سحبت في مدينه يونس سويسريه قرعه
الملحق المؤهل الى الدور ثمن النهائي من
مسابقه الدوري الاوروبي اوروبا ليج ابرز
مواجهه فيها ستجمع بين برشلونه الاسباني
ومانشستر يونايتد الانجليزي على ان تكون
مباراه الذهاب في كامبنو في السادس عشر من
فبراير من العام المقبل
انطلقت جلساته قضيه الفرنسي بين يمين مندي
مدافع المنتخب فريق مانشستر سيتي وشريكه
في القضيه اللي هو السهم ماتوري في قاعه
محكمه تشيستر في انجلترا ويواجه بندي سبعه
اتهامات بالاغتصاب والاعتداء بدوره وجهه
واستاهمه توري سته اتهامات بالاغتصاب
ويمكر رجلان هذه الاتهامات واتحق مندي
بستي قادمه من هناك 2017 وفاز مع الفريق
بالدوري ثلاث مرات وبكاس الرابطه
الانجليزيه مرتين
فقال نادي ساوثامبتون الانجليزي مدربه
النمساوي رالف هالسنه هوتيل بعد النتائج
المتواضعه للفريق الذي يحتل المركز السابع
عشر المهدد بالهبوط وكان سوف تلقى خساره
كبيره امام نيوكاسل يونايتد باربعه اهداف
فقد يونيون برلين صداره لصالح بايرن ميونخ
بخسارتها امام موبايل ليفركوزن بخمسه
اهداف في الدوري ضمن منافسات الجوله
الثالثه عشر من الدوري الالماني اهداف
لقاء جاءت في الشوط الثاني حيث افتتحها
روبرت اندرس اصحاب الارض امام فريقه
السابق مباشره بعد بدايه الشوط واضافه
موسى دياب في هدفين في دقيقتين السادس
والثامنه والخمسين قبل ان يضيف ادم لوزك
على الهدف الرابع في محمد الخامس بصمتها
ماتش البكر في الدقيقه السادسه والسبعين
تعد هذه الهزيمه هي لك اكبر مليون هذا
الموسم يتوقف على اثرها عند 26 نقطه في
المركز الثالث في الامارات
نقطه في المركز الرابع
عجز بالفيكه من صدارته للدوري البرتغالي
بعد فوزه على يشتريل ب 5 اهداف مقابل هدف
في الجوله الثانيه عشر
تتحدث في الدقيقه الخامسه والعشرين وضعف
زميله انطونيو سلفن نتيجه بعدها بخمس
دقائق قبل ان يضيف السلبي الهدف الثالث
لبنفيكا في مجاعه الرباعيه بتوقيعه اجواو
وماريو في الدقيقه ال 67 قبل ان يختفي
مارستتش مهرجان الاهداف بهدف الخامس
وبعدها سجل هيشتري الهدف عبر السيلفي
لتنتهي المباراه
نهايه الموجز الرياضي عوده وضح تفضلها
[موسيقى]
شكرا لعبد الله في تصريح اليوم في العربيه
كما يعرف في اسرائيل
من اجلي بث الرساله طمئن للاقليات في
الداخل من دون الاشاره طبعا للفلسطينيين
انضج تحديدا في عضويته السابقه بحركه
بحركه كاخ المسلحه المحظوره ام في ادانته
جنائيا بالتحريض ضد العرب ام في رفضه
للدوله الفلسطينيه ان في دعوته لتفكيك
السلطه الى هنالك في صوره اليوم هناك ما
نضج ايضا ولكن في موزمبيق حبوب القهوه حان
وقت تشفيها وفرزها ربما
اصبح هي بالنسبه لمن يؤدون المهمه
الروتينيه لكنها بالنسبه للبعض مصيريه
تغير المناخ تقول ان القهوه ستفقد الكثير
من محصولها
افرزو المحاصيل يفرزوها جيدا لكن لا ترمي
شيئا ففي عالمنا المتوتر هذا احيانا ما
تكون القهوه باهميه الخبز واحيانا اكثر